the Joe Rogan experience what weight do
you walk around it about one if I'm
completely just kind of like
bullshitting doing whatever I've gotten
to his eyes like 195 when you're in
training like when you get and like save
your for weeks on where you're 85 years
old 1 84 85 you're cutting a lot of
weight man yeah yeah I mean that's uh do
you see yourself ever moving to 70 or no
I'm not not 70 necessarily just because
though those guys they're you at that
point you're talking about a frame issue
you know you got a guy said like six
foot one and you know they're just it's
it's a different it's a different body
style you know I trained with a lot of
them high level welterweights too you
know it's a different body style right
I'm more suited for 155 it's just with
you know some of the things that I got
to play around with I think will keep
happening in the upcoming months
I didn't project that I would fight
again until July or so so a lot of the
things that I was doing diet-wise was
kind of getting to that and they
approached me with this barbell as a
fight maybe like eight weeks earlier
than that so I just had to do it at to
do so is it a matter of just you didn't
taper off quick enough or you just came
in too heavy before you started you know
it was just it was just the timing wise
you know I missed it by one pound yeah
yeah it something on that time in that
I've really got to figure out and that
was the biggest problem with with the
Tony Ferguson fight you know I can break
it down for you wait so usually uh you
know I'm normally about 185 through six
weeks of diet I can usually diet down to
about 76 77 like that's where I'm
optimistic cut so the week of the fight
the Tuesday I'm 76 you know I saved that
all the way until you know I overload my
body with water and you know cuz flush
out some of the the sodium and the carbs
and all that
I saved the rest of that up until the
day before and I try and cut as much as
I can as because I wanted to spend as
little the time dehydrated that
dehydrated as possible and I think
that's some of the problem with having
these early morning weigh-ins is the
time an issue of it and as you wake up
and then you have to start from the time
you wake up rather than if it's at 4:00
o'clock in the afternoon like it used to
be you'd be able to do it all throughout
the day yeah
yeah I can cut more you know reasonably
through the morning you know you can
wait like if you had more time you
would've been able to make it oh yeah
absolutely 1% yeah my time thing yeah
yes I got confused when they were doing
this early morning winds I thought you
had like like from 8 a.m. to 4 o'clock
right right that's right yeah
I thought if you weigh in early go ahead
way and early but they gave you the time
yeah I mean I'm not really I don't
really know the solution either you know
I don't think nobody really knows the
solution to that problem the the the
timeframe because you are seeing a lot
of guys miss weight because of that and
I think that's that's one of the biggest
problems and not only that but guys are
going to sleep completely dehydrated and
sleeping through the night 20 pounds
dehydrated that's a lot of water coming
from your blood your blood gets thicker
your heart rate slows down when you when
you sleep I mean you know I try my best
not to spend as much time dehydrated his
partner so it's just a timing issue on
that last one especially when you see
guys like those on Joe's that just can't
do it anymore and he goes up to 70 he
looks better than ever what do you think
about that it's always an option for me
it would be an option now like I would I
would entertain the right fight at it
for sure
it's just right now at the state of it
is you know they're doing this [ __ ]
interim title and you know tyrants
sitting right there and it's it's a lot
of movement it's not a lot of movement
at the top right now so 155 just more
fights interests me it's bigger
challenges I think the guys are honestly
better at 155 170 maybe in a future but
you know it's got to be the right type
of fight or something
yeah there well there's so many good
fighters now from I mean you go all
across the board I mean pretty much
every weight class that's strong now but
yeah I agree I think 55 is probably the
strongest weight class right yeah and it
is so strong that you can make a
165-pound out of me I don't I really
don't see what what the holdup is on it
it was 65 to a 75 I grabbed because we
have so many guys that you know can
bounce between those and you'll have a
whole new top 15 a whole new champion
and they'll be just as strong as any
other two weight classes next to it I
couldn't agree more I think it's very
important that we spread it out better I
think ten pounds is reasonable you know
I mean the way boxing has it they just
you know they have a 54 and then they
have a 60 that seems a little ridiculous
47 and they have a 54 I think you'd be
better off with 10 just said straight up
10 pounds that's reasonable but when you
go from like
85 to 205 that shit's crazy some people
even 55 to 70 because most guys you know
like a normal-sized guy is about my size
one hundred eighty-five hundred ninety
pounds hmm that puts you in that in that
middle you know you got guys like me
with a lot of muscle where I'm not gonna
lose a lot of fat in between you know
right even for this one I was 177 but I
was born a half percent body fat you
know I couldn't really lean you can't
get too much more lean than that
a 64 and a half somebody fighting weight
in ya before well I was four and a half
percent maybe two weeks before the fight
I said what are you getting calipers are
you doing how they totally testing over
at the U in the water not over at the
peoc especially anything yeah they've
got like so the scales aren't that good
yeah here's the thing about those scales
those scales when you hold on to those
things I mean some of them are okay but
the best way they say is submerging you
there's a submerge one and there's
another one that uses some sort of like
electricity thing like you lie in a bed
and I think that the Performance
Institute has that too they're
explaining that [ __ ] to me yeah yeah the
the the full scanner yeah done that a
few times but it's much quicker much
easier just get on the scale and as long
as it's real low four and a half percent
sounds it does but as long as it's it's
still the same measurement you know one
obtain as my last fight for the Tony
fight I was five and a half percent on
so as long as it's in the same with the
same CalPERS yeah I mean you know that
you're basically on point yeah exactly I
can compare it at least but again I
can't get much that much leaner you know
it's mostly just gonna come out water if
they add a 65 then you know I've got ten
more pounds of water that I don't have
to cut up
[Applause]